il sera peut être l'une des stars de
cette route 2016 harangue le var en sept
ans a été désigné par le parc zoologique
de thoiry pour pronostiquer les
résultats des matchs de l'équipe de
france pendant la compétition
en fait on lui propose trois gammes elle
avec
le drapeau de chaque équipe plus
l'option match nul et dans chaque gamme
l on met une petite friandise c'est à
dire une souris donc on fait en sorte
que les gamelles soit équidistante
il n'y a pas de gamelles plus facile à
atteindre que l'autre harangue a été
choisi pour ses mensurations deux
sportifs 2 m 20 pour 40 kg de muscles si
on le sort dans son enclos extérieur on
peut le voir en fait faire le tour du
propriétaire rapidement ces animaux sont
capables quand même de faire des pointes
en course à 20 km/heure après avoir
pronostiqué la victoire de la france
contre la roumanie lors du premier match
le spécialiste à sang froid avait prédit
un match nul contre l'albanie
une prédiction exacte jusqu'à la 90e
minute et l'ouverture du score d'antoine
griezmann
les bleus l'emportent finalement 2-0
la seule chose en fait c'est qu'on avait
oublié de lui spécifier qu'il y avait
aussi les arts il fallait tenir compte
des arrêts de jeu et donc lui il avait
pronostiqué match nul ce qui a été le
cas jusqu'au 90 minutes de temps
réglementaire
donc je pense qu'on peut l'excuser pour
sa part en train de corriger cette
erreur de débutant ce week-end pour le
match de la france contre la suisse